a vital operation to save lives
but every day this evacuation continues
the greater the security risk to those
involved
and it's not just from the taliban or
the sheer volume of people trying to
flee
terrorist groups like al qaeda and
islamic state are also a key concern
we are very mindful that we are very
very
uh vulnerable or should these terrorists
choose to do something and that's why
the bravery of our soldiers and indeed
you know of of many of those people from
other nations doing that job is is
amazing they are literally
out there amongst uh very very desperate
people
and the situation could get more
insecure this is kabul airport the focus
of the rescue effort
it's all happening on the military side
secured by u.s british and other allied
forces
while the civilian end under taliban
control is shut
as the exit deadline for western troops
looms terrorist threats at this site are
growing
officials have warned about the risk of
an islamic state suicide bomber
potentially targeting crowds of
desperate afghans massing outside the
various entrance points
then there's the prospect of a terrorist
cheating his way onto an evacuation
flight and being able to pose a threat
on foreign soil
and there's also the danger of militants
targeting aircraft as they take off and
land with mortar or machine gun fire
isis hasn't had a real
large attack and sometimes and the world
is watching this situation right now and
so i think they might think this is an
opportunity for us to demonstrate some
sort of spectacular event
with the united states confirming a plan
to withdraw by next tuesday the window
to launch such an attack is closing
so too the ability to catch an
evacuation flight
it means a greater chance of accidental
deaths if crowds again surge in a rush
to leave
the only muted danger is from the
taliban who've allowed this military
evacuation to run its course
provided it finishes on time
debra haynes sky news